Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number, which is
two one nine two David P. Totally different vibe
today for voicemail. It's a very personal
voicemail segment. Take a listen to this.
Speaker 5: Hey, David, this is Doug,
I'm from Atlanta, Georgia. I'm 19,
and I just had a question about what you eat for
breakfast. Honestly, I think you should start a
health segment, maybe or even on your
clips or something because everyone,
everyone can benefit from David Tips.
Speaker 1: Well, listen, I am not going to give
any health advice here that I am not qualified to
do that. And you should go to. I don't know who,
what doctor, nutritionist. I don't know. I will
tell you my typical breakfast repertoire. We need
a break from the serious stuff, folks. Please
don't come after me. Don't, don't go. Actually,
get a lot of questions about my breakfast.
I am not a big savory for breakfast guy.
I'm sorry. I'm not a big sweet for breakfast
guy. I'm more of a savory for breakfast guy. So
sometimes I'll have a croissant and a coffee. All
right now, I know the crust is somewhat sweet, but
that's like as sweet as I would go. No marmalade
jams, preserves or Cooley's on it whatsoever. Just
a plain croissant got to be a good great. You
want crunchy on the outside, you know, fluffy
on the inside and a coffee. But more typically
like at home, I don't tend to have croissants
typical for breakfast for me. I will saute up
a slice or two of turkey, bacon, turkey, bacon,
turkey folks, not regular bacon and an egg over
medium and then half an avocado. That's like a
perfect breakfast for me from the standpoint
of savory and from the standpoint of protein
plus healthy fats plus fiber. It's it's really
got everything there. Sometimes now this this
people know about my love affair. We fell
in love with sweet potatoes. And if I've got
roasted sweet potatoes from a previous meal is
leftovers. I will sometimes take a sweet potato
and make some vertical cuts, almost to get
me like an English muffin size and shape two
little discs of sweet potato, which I will saute
up egg over medium on top of the sweet potato
almost like Benedict, except instead of English
muffin. It's the sweet potato. That's not bad.
I think that's basically right. I mean, it's
something like that I might make avocado toast if
I'm more of a bread mood or something like that,
but those those are my breakfast. I'm not into
I haven't had cereal and who knows how long? I'm
a fan of oatmeal, but not for breakfast. I like
yogurt, but not for breakfast. All right,
let's move on because this is just a waste
of everybody's time. I hope I've answered the
question sufficiently on the bonus show today.
European Parliament calls for a flat out ban
on facial recognition. Some people say ban the
virus and get rid of it. European Parliament is
saying ban facial recognition in Texas. A man
has been sentenced to 15 months in prison for
posting COVID 19 hoaxes on social media. Very
serious. And Los Angeles has indeed approved that
strict COVID vaccination mandate that on Monday,
we said could be coming. They have approved it.
They have approved it. I will talk about all of
those stories and more on today's bonus show. How
do you get access to the bonus show? It could not
be simpler. You go to join Pacman dot com and
you get a membership. If you'd like a discount,
you can use the coupon code better. 21.
And if you'd rather pledged via Patreon,
you can also do that by going to Petrie. Uncommon
David Pakman show people worried where it was pat
yesterday on the bonus show. Pat will be back
with us soon. Just me on today's bonus show
and tomorrow Pat will be back with us very, very
soon after the Columbus Day holiday. Join today.
I'll see you on the bonus show, Pat and I will
Unidentified: see you very, very soon.